hello and welcome it's October 1st
2024 and we're in quarterly Roundtable
number three for the active inference
Institute welcome to the ACM Institute
we're a participatory online Institute
that is communicating learning and
practicing applied active inference you
can find more information at these links
this is recorded in an archive live
stream
so please provide feedback so we can
improve our work all backgrounds and
perspectives are welcome and we'll
follow a video etiquette for live
stream okay today in the quarterly Round
Table we'll go over a few Institute
updates look at some developments
occurring in projects and then talk a
little bit about what'll be happening in
the last quarter of 2024 how we'll be
setting up for next year before we jump
in blue or Alex want to make any
comments or say
hello sure hi uh excited to round this
year out with the ecosystem paper and
the Symposium and um yeah looking
forward to 2025 and all the updates
we'll make
then yeah hey everyone and possibly I
will bring it into the live what we
shortly discuss in the beginning and
before the stream that uh looks like for
our current and next uh round tables we
will talk more and more about some
project
results and that's great that we see
more and more projects and more
developments not only some specific
plans all right so people watching live
feel free to write any questions or
anything in the live chat we'll keep an
eye on it
all right first at The Institute
scale here's an overview slide you can
screenshot a bunch of stable links
that'll help start you on your journey
email us join the Discord check out some
projects learn about the ecosystem find
out more structured ways to get involved
stay updated with video or newsletter
check out fellows programs
organizational Partnerships and provide
fin cial support bunch of short links
okay as blue alluded to our
main Institute level focus and
collaboration for the next six weeks or
so is the versioning of this ecosystem
and Institute paper so we wrote the
first version as a big team in
2023 with visuals and a lot of different
discussion and hammering it out a lot of
really interesting points and now we're
in the versioning the first versioning
heading towards the second snapshot
version of what'll be a large living
document that'll provide many entry
points and many paths through different
things happening at the Institute and
also at the ecosystem and clarify the
relationships between them like what
would be impactful for the active
inference ecosystem to do what kinds of
capacities could it build what kinds of
differences could it make what would the
Institute have to do and be in order to
support that and what would we need from
a support or participation perspective
for how that would come to be so over
the next six weeks there'll be a lot of
collaboration and discussion synchronous
and asynchronous no one is going to add
everything to every page but just like
it always is except more this is a
project where we just jump in and make
many light touches and it's been awesome
already to see how people have added
things to these different pages and made
structural suggestions there's one week
left if you want to register go to
ecosystem. active influence. Institute
and fill out the form and you'll jump in
and then for the last five weeks with
whoever's on board then there's already
20 or 30 people who will be co-authors
and are writing in these pages over the
next 5 weeks we'll come together set up
a few synchronous and asynchronous ways
of people focusing their contributions
and then we'll snapshot the version two
in the days before the Symposium and
it's really an important way for people
whether they've been largely on the
sidelines watching or whether they've
been involved for years how can we hear
from people at the end of this year and
help set a course for next year so
there'll be new visuals new fun
discussions blue or Alex want to give
any thoughts on this document or how we
use it or or anything else about
it uh you mentioned visuals and yes I
still see in this picture we have from a
last uh
version uh it looks very nice in terms
of visuals but also it was uh defining
structure for our activities how we see
Institute as organization which how it
operates and how it's
breakdowns in organizational sense which
functions we need to parate such entity
and so on everything was uh like
basically in place and uh somehow
planned for current vision and based on
experience from the year working in
projects and changes in ecosystem
definitely we will work on contents of
the paper but finally we will need to
update visuals and I hope our new
visuals will be even more attractive and
defining in terms of structure for our
future
works thank you
blue well that's a tough act to
follow uh no I'm just excited to see
what pans out and um you know it's it's
nice for people to put their
expectations for the institute for the
next steps for where they think we are
right now it's nice to see that like
from other people bes besides just us uh
it kind of lets us update like oh well
maybe we're we are where we think we are
or maybe we're not where where we think
we are and what could we do to be better
so it's a fun process also without going
too much into it it's amazing how much
the document writing environment has
evolved in the last year like a year ago
we were talking about a linear document
and how to make it readable and
accessible all these different kinds of
considerations then take that document
already in the last few months I was
able to smash it up against a bunch of
Grant openings and get quite a ways
towards translations into many languages
translations to many audiences
applications to Grants all these
different sorts of things augmented to a
pretty great first draft status using
llms so having these kinds of
comprehensive documents and living
documentation that can have accurate
information about what is the
organization who's available who has
what kinds of capacities that kind of
information can flow directly in uh
Grant Pathways so it's just really
exciting how how that can play out all
right second major piece of the coming
few months and weeks will be the fourth
applied active inference Symposium it's
going to be November 3 1 to
2024 uh it'll be free and online we also
hope that there'll be some satellite
physical events for people who want to
do a watch party or live stream from
some physical location the uh opening
session will be with Carl friston
there'll be first uh session on just
recapping what is the applic
environment look like what has changed
since 2021 when we had the first applied
active Symposium with Carl uh what's
happened this past year and then the
second and third hour will be live
stream 58.2 so that'll be the third
discussion that we will be having on the
renormalization group advances and then
there's going to be a whole host of
other
presenters sharing everything from tools
and their case studies their updates
their successes and challenges in
applying actim and also we'll have a lot
of hackathon open source code
collaboration
opportunities it will be very welcome
and open for beginners and all questions
and we'll look to curate questions and
help make sense of things together and
we'll be sharing more information on
that in
October anything else that either of
you'd like to add about the
[Music]
Symposium um that's great that we have
uh like this initiative became stable
and we have each year we have
Symposium uh but if you remember we like
initially trying to choose format which
will be most valuable for our online
community which is growing and so on but
from very beginning we was focused on
that uh applied uh stance of
uh of the topics uh because we
understand that which rapidly grow in
field in terms of theory and researches
researchers working in the
field but finally from uh like systems
engineering viewpoints we always need to
have some understanding how it should be
applied finally and this year I believe
in terms of developments of tools and
Frameworks like Eric
siner uh it's really became more and
more close to real life applications and
we see around
some like prototypes and some artificial
Bots are working their on
offline and yes we need to be Aline uh
with ecosystem with our partners and
participants and so on
and see this have his focus on applying
active inference and che check like uh
each year with each others in a field to
share developments and
perspectives that's an exciting like
sneak preview about the renormalization
group too I'm excited to uh to peep
that yeah and it's just exciting to hold
the
open and plural space where we have
research developments and applications
all the way on through domain experts
and it's one thing to hear about well
active inference could be applied to
supply chain here and to this kind of
thing here and then having that two-way
street with a domain expert and maybe
just their verbal account of the
situation or the systems modeling
they've already done with the kinds of
ontologies narratives formal documents
tools Etc that they already have may
even be closer than many people suspect
to having a functioning active inference
model so it's a great time we'll touch
on some of these points uh coming up but
again if you'd like to be a presenter or
if you'd like to facilitate some other
kind of interactive session if you'd
like to be a sponsor we can share
information on that just go to the
Symposium page and that's where
information will
be uh a quick note here on important
developments of the format of Symposium
itself I believe it's about that uh
hakon sessions and we will put
additional attentions and efforts to
organize this part of Symposium in best
possible way uh and it's kind of
development of the format and really
possibly in a few years uh the most uh
activities of such symposiums will be on
on hakon site
see yeah thanks I I agree live chats are
awesome and the the live interaction of
live streams is awesome also a lot of
trainings can be done like model streams
ahead of time and having symposia and
convenings where people can just rapidly
break through many many layers of
uncertainty it can go from like
listening to hours of podcasts or
reading papers and thinking okay it
could apply here but I don't really see
how or I don't even even see that I
don't see how and then all of a sudden
when you're on the team and talking to
people and the code is out and that the
sketching is happening it could just
happen so fast and it's just really
exciting learning
experience okay about research fellows
so our three current fellows Anna John
FIS and John Boy are still active
they've been research fellows for a
couple of months now and our next round
of review is going to to be in about 2
weeks so if you're considering putting
in a research fellow application and you
want to be considered for this second
cohort get in contact whenever you can
and uh we'll continue with a rolling
deadlines around research fellows and
other kinds of fellows so it's been
awesome to see each of the three
continue their their projects in very
unique ways and there will be a lot more
to come with more fellows
on organizational
Partnerships we've continued and have a
have a great collaboration with first
principles first with John clippinger
and the fp1 project and several other
discussions with organizational Partners
these are with financial or within kind
donations and support and there's a lot
of opportunities for different
organizations that want to contribute to
the open source ecosystem want to learn
and apply actim faster want to give
strategic input to The Institute and
access the community all these different
sorts of things that Partners can help
synergize and and um collaborate on any
comments on
anything
no uh let me add something that yes that
two important Direction uh of research
fellows and partnership with
organization are strategic for this year
and we see results see uh work working
of people on our aligned goals uh that's
great and we will develop this direction
yes for research fellows it's two weeks
to make decisions and put your
application if you see some perspectives
and we as institution will support you
in this way
and for Partnerships with organization
yes we will uh continue this way and
always happy to see in new like players
in ecosystem and if you as
organizational entities see
some affordances which can be realized
together let's
discuss cool yeah a lot of things
happening with us writing letters of
support or being possible contractors on
grants range to us applying for Grants
and including other organizations so
doing together what we can't do
alone our philanthropy continues donate.
active inference do Institute now has
some nice drop-down options for
supporting a certain project with a
restricted donation so this means that
the funds for the donation go to the
project um we're a
501c3 organization that maybe matter for
some donors and while we are applying to
Grants some of which we'll describe
later on we're currently an all
volunteer operation and donations are
and will be vital to ensure that there's
a sustainability to what we're working
on so onward we go with philanthropy any
comments here
and I'm bringing in a live Super Chat
from
upcycle thank you
upcycle our philanthropy program at
work nice um some updates on our uh
social
media the project prepare and measure
form continues to operate like with the
fellows the partners several other
aspects that we've been
discussing I'm really happy we have
these quarterly round taes and the
newsletters it's easy to forget how
quickly these structural changes come
into play it was only this year when a
lot of those structures and affordances
came into being so we continue to see
many people propos projects some of
which we'll review and having this
always open measure opportunity for
people to share ranging from what's
happening in their internship to their
research lab to their company and these
channels will just continue to be
important as the ecosystem grows and
just like any other ecosystem no
organism is in all places at once so
having a a culture of sharing what is
intended to be shared and having the
ways for people to select and using
synthetic methods to to expand and
distill as needed there's some extremely
exciting
possibilities just on our oh Alex SK
for uh yeah possibly get back to yeah to
this slide and I just take a place of
some newcomer which is first time on our
stream of such discussion and see seen
this picture and this structure and
connections uh to some specific
organizational process what we have it
could be not clear but for me it's a
great picture what we really have pieces
changes in our organizational process
which is based on our first principal
materials what we have in Institute and
having understanding and seeing now how
it's starting to work I just want to
highlight for people who possibly not
understand from the beginning what is
presented here it's really first
principles in works of organization and
possibly for your organization it's
could be interested to take a course of
physics as information processing and
take some principles uh into your work
as we done it for
hours thanks
here we have kind of a formal
organizational summary with the bodies
and The rhythms the scientific Advisory
Board the officers and the board of
directors we had a board of directors
meeting last week that was very
insightful and in the coming weeks and
months we'll be preparing and already
the applications and the information on
these positions exists on our website
and we'll be adding more information and
clarifying like what are these volunteer
positions what would be the kinds of
pragmatic and epistemic value that
somebody might glean or gain or
contribute from from working and
contributing this
way
okay those are the Institute type
activities now we'll have some shorter
project
oriented
sections so here are the Ed active
projects at The Institute we have the
ontology project this has been
continuing had many fun conversations in
the Discord people learning using AI
using natural methods to explore the
ontology audiovisual production will
come to textbook group will come to and
active inference Journal also continuing
to to explore what's possible with
developing and augmenting
transcripts in the textbook group we
continue cohort six and cohort 7
continue on and as we're now about 2 and
1 half years out from the publication of
the textbook and closing in on six and a
half cohorts completed we're thinking a
lot about how does
this role that the textbook served in
2022 and
2023 how is that updating in
24 as people who have been through it
one or three cohorts start to move on to
other research projects what kinds of
entry points exist and how how can we
continue to to use the templates and the
approaches like using generative AI to
help unpack math as well as the the math
learning group that octopus is
facilitating how can we use the onology
to help connect natural language
readings of equations with different
kinds of situations and studies how can
we Cate questions and discourse that
people ask and and help promote
collaboration all these different ways
so the group's still active and also
it'll be continuing to to develop as we
change our uh offerings depending on
what people want to do and what
facilitators want to contribute
what in production we've had 26 videos
over the last few months for a total of
539 videos
overall here were the streams from the
last few
months there were 1 two 3 four five math
art streams with shanana Dobson and
Friends covering a a wide variety very
exciting and all over the place and math
already in the active infer an streams
I've been working in the active infrance
code repo developing open source code
for a a variety of different
settings we've had 11 guest
streams on topics like reinsurance that
was yesterday thrilling thrilling
reinsurance live
stream limits of the brain and
predicting events fellow John Bo with a
cognitive narrative
ecosystem guest stream 86 on biological
neurons and how biometic and and
heterogenous Computing methods contrast
with reinforcement
learning coming more from a
computational side David blumen and also
talking about reinforcement learning and
active inference Robert
Warden with a pair of live streams on
the the projective wave theory Raph and
Charles talking about different kinds of
cognition in in natural and llm type
systems fellow Anna talking about her
ongoing Book Project and Josh bongard
talking about embodied intelligence
really cool guest
streams and
then several other
streams ran way in a model stream giving
one of the most distilled and Powerful
unpacking of how active inference is
similar and different than reinforcement
learning and meta RL
methods uh discussion of quantum infer
ants and about Quantum measurements and
Quantum information studies and active
inference Toby Sinclair SMI from the
category theory side discussing
structured active inference which is
very promising way that active inference
methods are starting to be appli to apis
and other kinds of computational
settings uh the
closing season finale SL reflection with
Darius from insights turning the tables
asking him about how the insights series
went and and those uh 23 prior episodes
were some of the coolest and and most
viewed
conversational uh onboarding points for
a lot of different thinkers and ideas
and two art streams on on different work
at the intersection of predictive
processing active Aesthetics
art a lot of fun discussion so if
anyone's interested
in the planning part in inviting guests
or curating the suggestions from others
and just helping follow through on
invites and just getting things planned
if you're interested in audio visual
production manual craft production or
using synthetic methods to produce in
ways that people have not been able to
produce before if you want to help on
the journal side there's a lot of ways
to help improve this whole
process okay on to Reiner
updates here the Reiner projects uh
these are projects where where people
can get Hands-On
with coding and with knowledge
engineering it's been a productive month
for the RX andf fur. JL learning group
at the at the Institute this short URL
will pop you into our Kota where there's
always uh developments and things being
posted but this month we submitted two
grants with some partially overlapping
teams that was exciting um earlier in
September we submitted a farmworks
decentralized AI agents for personalized
solutions that was a future of Life
Institute grant program about uh
centralized Ai and power asymmetries and
also pretty fun to then put up the grant
as a pre-print so whether we get it or
not we're
co-authors we go on with a show and uh
we can communicate that around without
even knowing whether we've gotten it or
not and we don't and then just a few
days ago we submitted a uh multi-agent
AI safety Grant to a foresight Institute
program and this one that the tentative
meme project name was Village validating
inference for large scale agent
governance
ecosystems so we'll see where this goes
and even apart from the grant
applications there have been just many
developments with RX and fur and the
application ecosystem so it's quite
exciting to see where it's all
going and then here's just the other
projects that are in the actm
ecosystem
uh really cool that people have proposed
all these different things and and so
much also happens outside of these
tables so big thanks to all those who
have put up their projects so that
others can join in and learn more about
them and uh put in the the measurements
and that's how we'll share more specific
detail any more comments blue or
Alex no I'm good
thanks okay for live Chatters feel free
to write any questions otherwise here's
just one final slide
here we are looking in the mirror Life's
a
blur even if we could record it all what
would it really say and
so all these different views and and
angles that we take dayto day how is
active inference helping us navigate
this how can surprise pragmatic and
epistemic
value how can all all of these things
that we're talking about be their own
intrinsic meaningful contributions and
also help us in the in the times
between This Is A View From The topos
Institute blue and I went to a small
meeting there just a few weeks ago
learning about category Theory but
that's what it looks like from the nth
floor of a building in
Berkeley
and the walk continues through whatever
we suppose it to
be
um I'll wait a minute just if there's
any live chat questions or anything
people that uh want
to ask otherwise um what would be your
closing thoughts blue and
[Music]
Alex um possibly I will uh get back to
educ education and that experience of of
textbook
group and yes uh right questions you
raised about how we should use that
experience from that learning on
specific textbook but also I believe
that during that way we set up and
tested and evolved uh uh the methodic
process itself and currently we for our
needs if you'll see some new textbook or
course we can organized uh group
learning in the same way and possibly
from some moment it's also could be
affordance from some other projects or
institutes or some someone who who are
searching looking for new approach on
such collaborative ways of learning and
we can share possibly like templates in
Koda how to enabled or have some other
provide some other support for such
activities for any others valuable
knowledge
yes at like multiple scales I mean if
there's a time slot for something that
you want to jump in and stick by make
the suggestion if there's another
textbook group with a a similar
structure another book or another
another way it it's all whatever
volunteers step up to do so we have a
lot
of
latitude don't let the structures in
play give a blind spot to the degrees of
freedom that still
exist
blue for me I'm just excited like to see
um you know every time like we're
rounding out the year and we're coming
to like the close of our activities for
24 and um like where will we be a year
from now is always like like I'm always
surprised by how far we've come and not
only the Institute but overall um just
what what's possible and and um coming
to the Forefront with all the synthetic
knowledge uh and and what does that mean
and and like will synthetic knowledge be
um as useful more useful will people
like want real knowledge again someday
like a human human generated like will
We crave that will it will it become so
pervasive or I don't know I'm just
always curious to see um where where
that's taking us because it seems like
uh kind of the cat is out of the bag or
the Pandora's Box has been opened and um
the possibilities really seem seem
endless so I'm excited to see what where
we where we're at at this time in 25 and
um you know how how much will have been
done and how much will have changed and
and then the court that is still the
same
awesome okay
so stable links to check out if you're
watching in nearish real time join on in
to the ecosystem project or come along
for another versioning
run similarly for the
Symposium okay thanks and Alex thank you
upcycle everyone else okay bye thanks
everyone thank you